some loud movie and it's had hell I'm
not lazy when that Pokemon episode was
banned overseas because all the kids had
epileptic yeah that's the kind of movie
hello reject nation Greg Alba here with
epic voice guy John Bailey what up
people so we're gonna do an episode of
trailers revisited today you didn't work
on the Man of Steel trailers did you now
that was before my before my eighty
artists my time well chose revisited is
it's a segment where we revisit trailers
that we determine how if they're spoiler
if ik if they represent the tone well
and sometimes for the older ones it's
fun to go back and be like man I
remember what I was thinking when I
first saw this one of the highly
requested ones is the third trailer for
Man of Steel but do it a lot of trailers
are visited for Marvel movies I figure
we mix it up with a DC film today matte
steel trailer three I'm assuming you've
seen it I have then let's watch the
trailer input yeah I love this score I
work out too it finds the kind of music
I think of
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you'll be an outcast
this is the scene except what's a lot
louder they show the first the whole
first section of the mission just so
much more chaos the part where he's like
one of the child aspired to something
greater
oh yeah this was a sick-ass trailer
he saw what Clark did
he peed his pants you know the answer to
are we alone in the universe
you know I like this movie but I already
feel like the trailer is better than the
movie
yeah I agree I do like them and they
couldn't CG at that beard
they'll rest behind you little stumble
they will fall
cousin time oh I have comments to make
because this still feels like Superman
in a lot of ways you know this feels way
to a beef in a way to positive yeah
[Music]
he was convinced that the world was
ready this is a fascinating trailer what
do you think
is that everybody's favorite some men
see humor there's no humor in that movie
okay
that was let me get my thoughts together
for one second that's a fascinating
trailer because it's in the movie and it
doesn't necessarily misrepresent the
movie I mean it represents the movie but
it's the Reader's Digest version of the
entire movie it's a positive because
this is not a darkened version that the
movie is this looked like you would have
the right blend a more toned down space
yeah you get that vibe in this trailer
and the other thing too is the way the
trailers lay the clips make it look like
it's gonna play out in linear fashion
exactly that's exactly what I was
thinking we're literally played from
scene to scene to scene to scene they
kind of give away that Lois is gonna
figure out who he is they show the
entire origin part yeah yeah well in
terms of like the parts where he's the
kid and he's growing up it finds a
spaceship like this movie actually does
a thing where it goes from his time in
the present and then it cuts to
flashback it's hard to communicate that
in trailer this makes it look like it's
gonna play out okay he's a baby he grows
up yeah and then you feel the adventure
instead of you're like you're watching
this weird structure in a bright and
colorful and like positive neck cracking
millions of people getting murdered
the thing I noticed about it was the
scenes that felt effective like even the
opening part with jor-el he's putting
kollel and the ship and then and he's
seen when he's younger or any dialogue
scene actually that they're showing here
it's less noisy in the trailer yeah
where is like even all that stuff on
Krypton it's like a lot of [ __ ] give you
a seizure yeah it's loud you don't have
a big screen where you can't really
focus on everything because the movies
more handheld than the trailer leads you
to believe yeah it's like yeah that's
the shots are handheld here but this
movies like very shaken cam it's like
when you turn the holes around on your
phone that stabilizes this trailer makes
you look a little bit more this trailer
makes a little
movie I want to see yeah the movie we
got I mean I'll be honest actually like
this movie I like it too I did I just I
didn't love it it had been more like the
trailer I think I would have loved it
you know if the movie played out in this
structure that this trailer represents I
think that's the biggest thing that's a
difference between the trailer and the
movie is the pacing of the film is kind
of all over the place it's kind of hyper
edited a lot right necessary the
structures a little weird at times
because this feels like okay oh yeah
back to one he's a kid act 2 right oh
maybe versus you know Teen murti versus
groan versus I become the hero but
because of the structure a lot of those
emotional moments like in the trailer
when he dons the Superman suit here I'm
like I'm feeling it it's Superman but
when the movie I'm like oh he's Superman
I'm such a small screen you don't see
the giant tough of hair I mean laser
vision in the mirror like you do a guy
who kind of feels like he doesn't belong
but looking for a place to belong the
weird part is even though I like the
movie I feel it more in the trailer yeah
like I really like the movie but I love
the trailer the way the trailer goes by
so quick they make you think that
there's gonna be a little bit of the
background I like the original because
that's what we got we were getting we
thought we were getting it like a
rebooted version of the original with
Christopher yeah just a so that first
scene in the movie where they explained
Krypton yeah that goes on a really long
time and that's what I mean it's noisy
yeah where is this scene lose like he
would get in the movie this way where he
thinks he's an earth kid and all of a
sudden he realized he's he has powers
yeah his dad finally explains you're not
human you're an alien we adopted you
you're not really from here you have
powers and abilities and I'm gonna teach
you to use them the right way and be
responsible they've done it that way I
think I liked it a lot better kind of
all over the place yeah they don't let
the scenes play out and this gives you
the impression that scenes will play out
and that's why I really harp on the
opening scene of this because even in
the movie there's so much chaos and so
much noise you don't even really feel
the effect of that said but here you
feel you feel jorelle's words but in the
movie itself I gathered the
Meishan actually now that I think about
it I may have worked on something for
this but I think original version it was
more of an homage to the original they
were looking for a setting like yeah
Marlon Brando you're looking for a
Marlon Brando kind of boys to kind of
like give a nod to what was gonna happen
oh okay and then you go into the new
stuff and I think that that didn't work
out right because people got confused
because they kind of did that what
Superman Returns yeah but some cool
things about this trailer though that I
really do like to other than showing
like a lot of the first half of the
movie it's not really spoiler heavy on
everything that goes on with Zod right
the stuff that goes they show you like
super yeah yeah you have to go frame by
frame to really see what's going on it's
very Clark it's Superman based which I
appreciate so it did leave a mystery
into how is this gonna be execute it's
not like the BBS second trailer oh yeah
it shows you everything
yeah this trailer actually does leave a
good mystery and intrigue there was a
lot more this is a sick-ass I remember
the only thing I didn't like about this
movie was realizing that Lois was not
gonna be brunette always know and she's
such an amazing actor like you couldn't
change your hair color they gave me I'm
glad they didn't make her stupid a
little bit of investigative journalism
like her real job yeah I used to get her
passing the old days like she really
knew she just didn't want to know you
know what I mean because that would
change things you know I mean that was
fun
it's fun to check out because I haven't
seen this tradition especially to the
consumers core I was beautiful
they let the trailers clips escalate
with the music that was beautiful I to
Daddy you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell
leave comments for what you think would
be a fun trailer to revisit people and
John Bailey
epic voice guy you could follow him on
social media and his own YouTube channel
as well whether that endeavor click on
let's say that don't say that I know I
know my gnomes are too lazy to click on
that most people have just let this
video play in their ear books
here at the end now I'm jealous at least
people watch your video to the end
they're not really watching they're
waiting for it to end